sono le delegazioni come sapete io
sappiamo che fare altrove ci sono marci
e ceste questo dobbiamo fare tipo quella
l'altra volta sel sinistra ma ora che
sto male la verità più bella di gta mai
creata togliti donne
e va bene questa cosa io sono c'è vi
rendete conto cosa non sapeva bene che
casino no ragazzi verso addio mio
aspetto se io ci arrivo con tanta
preghiera perché lui è anch'esso ragazzo
mi sembra sembrano più facilissimo bravo
regio per un millimetro non ci sono
arrivata qui allora ok però già capito
il tipo di contraccolpo per queste mappe
gli hanno capito niente rimasti fuori
andare più veloce di un anno netta in
autostrada diver fatto a cadere ma io ti
ho fatto che deve fare la spesa ma come
si fa come come fate andare dritti io
sono io sto io robot e che nome non
dobbiamo usare l'acceleratore ora è
mantenere con la leva
io sto provando il retro ma comunque
fatta la pensano marcia come march ma
come è possibile
adesso io gioco per buttare fuori staff
ma no non sarei giocando proprio per
vincere per poter fuori da questi ci
sono io lo so se stai vedendo questo
scendendo cioè vista da fiancate
occhio perché non posso crederci non
potevo frenare ma la grecia il contrario
ma no io il cazzo di preferivo lanza
aereo mi vedi davanti con sotto di te
quelle ramara farci non avevi ancora
preso la macchina aiuto aiutarlo che
evita brutta fare un po di fair play a
che ricorda come questo che territorio
la sua magari figli ma togliti ma cosa e
allora piano piano mentale un triennale
caprino come mi fermo premio frena
frenano con calma come la vecchietto
scendiamo che non guarda io so per quale
grazie di dio non mi apre manovra march
poi schiacciare quel pedale per favore
potete anche l'andamento in autostrada è
già un casino e c'è un casinò meglio di
prima però attenzione che stava chi è
più stabile
questo è più facile di prima sono
proprio all'ultimo no son caduto
l'ultimo non ci voglio credere
la ferma e calma calma calma posso darmi
un consiglio fatevi un giro con la
macchina e venete del calcio dritto in
teoria no non so più il paraurti alla
nato io porto bene che costa un sacro
che si veicola mesi lo vedo lo sbaglio
mai non ho che pago già mafia
ma quale passò proprio sarebbe nuova per
agazzi se viene se viene ciao non è
venuto ma chi è che è rimasto fermo lire
nel march boggetto no vabbè ragazzi se
riesco a fare sta roba è venuto alla
provata perchè ho preso march come rampa
c'è stato bello insomma per barbera mare
ne sono ancora la polaria è stato
bellissimo preso march come rampa è
stato divertentissimo
a questo poi la macchina col turbo né
gigante lo si può attivare come no
a fine vita non solo vengono subito così
fa ma devi chiedere tutto il turbo ma
devi cambiare per forza
ho fatto una roba alla fast and furious
sarà che mi sono salvato col turbo
dietro c'è un grande nome in un fenomeno
non ragazzi 93 questo ragazzo è stato
partorito in una rampa ho fatto la
giocata che lei perché per ora la rai
non saprei di farla mai la giocata
incredibile prego vi scongiuro il prego
state un po sottotono mi sbaglio ma
cos'è la 500 ai è questa e una
cinquecento pali mister bean non sei già
500 state facendo niente stiamo giocando
per buttare fuori io sto vedendo il
controllo è salvo chicca per scendere
ragazzi che veramente forse l'ho
inventata io e basta
va bene che macchina ice maker dai
adesso è adesso io visto che da adesso
una
non so niente di macchine però una pre
l'altra bella da dio l'ha capito no lui
non avrà cosa comunque no è una macchina
particolarmente bella e non so che tipo
di gesù tabià susta mappa però comunque
l'obiettivo è dare lenti perché non fa
niente
spesso senza ombra di dubbio stesso due
minuti da noi sono due o la macchina di
mister bean finalmente e ma noi siamo
quella dopo dopo un corna non è vero
comunque facili sia la macchina di
mister bean
ma io vorrei far esplodere allora
parlare di quanto avanti
amy che tra yard hata yoga marino
secondo me non è andato giù il primo
video lo sai perché non è andato giù
esatto quindi non so traguardando però
no no no no però ragazzi sapete che ho
trovato una tattica se posso permettere
piano infrenare no quando tu in corno
cosa che sa è che era l'auto che volava
però se più in corni con l'aereo
traguardo alla velocità della luce è
pentita solo in una macchina va
direttamente al traguardo senza passare
dalla rampa capito questo salto e basta
a salta si ci si ficca soldati pazzo ma
l'hai detto adesso ho fatto un sacco di
un chilometro e mezzo
devi saltare stesso quando ti in corda
col jazz aiuto al momento sono in auto
al contrario adesso voglio vedere se
funziona perché voglio rifare la stessa
cosa ha fatto prima buttandovi
direttamente con gente che mi trasformo
in macchina e vado direttamente di
vedere se forse va dipende dove il
traguardo è in una buona posizione
il ragazzo sta raillard dando veramente
secondo me viene la roba bellissima ho
capito comunque che devi fare
esatto ognuno di essi e vale andare a
piena velocità sulla rampa tramite il
jazz di e poi e poi non dovresti neanche
toccarla con la macchina capisci
vediamo insieme non lo so è ok vado ma
che macchina che io ci arrivo forse
forse c'erano un pò lento
no ci arrivava si è beccato la rampa
ragazzi se perché con la rampa ci arriva
sicuro che non ci arrivi
no non ci sono arrivato lì ci buttiamo
in tutti e tre insieme guai giusto
doveste quanto team ha un attimo
ecco la caduta anche vittoria morale
vera di lore dai questa allineati stessa
il momento che ci dobbiamo esserci ma
che bello che sto veicolo per più belli
ok 321 vadano via siamo una squadra di
casa ma perché siete così veloci voi
scusate lo so sarà il giallo e mi
rendevo ok allora bisognerebbe fenomeno
cioè stefan turbo nel che dico rimbalzi
noah rai si stanno sorgendo un po ma io
sono stato al contrario se non c'e la
prima incredibile non ce l'hai fatto che
partita è stata ben è stata combatte vi
è piaciuta tantissimo io ho trenta
secondi per finirla soligo terzo crede
con amara che è stato è stato bellissimo
successe di ogni ogni tre secondi se
c'era qualcosa la bellissima perché è
troppo riguarda la mia vita la mia vita
eccola mentre march sta accadendo
imperterrito
grazie ai farmaci che hanno partecipato
è stato molto divertente perché diceva
ragazzi si chiede anche anche quello di
manchester
lasciatemi mi piace noi ci diamo come
sempre cosa hai bisogno ciao ciao
[Musica]